Um,
so last time,
uh,
we start,
we started talking about tropical places where high productivity agriculture is
generally not just not possible.
And hence,
without productive agriculture you can't support a dense populations.
So those cultures grew up,
uh,
in time in places where plenty of land land was not filled up,
whose people that were scarce.
And so while individual women of course still had to control their fertility so
that the children,
infants that they had didn't die.
And there's many,
many things that they do for that.
The community cultural controls on fertility or generally absent cause for the
com the community point of view,
you always want to be,
uh,
at that time larger and among other reasons to protect your community from the
ravages of hostile,
hostile neighbors cause almost all of these communities or you just read any
history of any part of the world,
constant,
constant warfares as we've discussed a lot.
So,
uh,
of of many places in the world,
which one could describe traditional Africa provides some of the best examples
of how these cultures operate.
And again,
I want to emphasize that this is a tradition,
a picture of a traditional time and things are changing now extremely,
uh,
rapidly everywhere in the world,
including of course Africa.
Um,
as I showed you last time,
uh,
Africa really is different than the rest of world.
I showed you statistics comparing Morocco on the north coast of Africa,
included in the Mediterranean cultural zone.
You're crossed the Sahara,
you're in Asia or in Mali and totally different,
uh,
situation.
The number of children as much Ha,
uh,
that people have as much higher.
I showed you that the number of children that they want as much higher infant
mortality has come down in both places in Morocco.
The fertility responds to it in the share.
The fertility,
uh,
does not respond to it.
So,
uh,
while
we're going to win,
so we're going to discuss this region and using a lot of generalizations which
will not fit any particular,
uh,
culture.
Uh,
if you add up all of the birth rates,
statistics,
uh,
sub Saharan Africa has about twice the birth rate of North Africa.
And again,
it's all Sunni Muslim we're talking about.
So religion is not the difference,
but something else about the southern culture,
which we've been talking about,
which probably starts with the agriculture and then goes into other fields.
So,
uh,
and of all the things that are changing,
in Africa,
fertility,
the attitudes toward fertility,
again,
I'm always using fertility as the number of children a woman actually has and
not her ability to have children.
The attitudes toward fertility are sort of the most resistant to change.
So these societies have what you might call a culture of reproduction in which
the central idea is that of lineage of family and it's line of male ancestors
and the prime duty and these cultures is to keep the lineage going.
Of course,
you've all read stuff about China.
China is not a traditional,
China's not particularly different than this.
And the important thing is to provide descendants for the ancestors.
Not only is your own future if you don't have the sentence,
your own future as a shade.
That's sort of a spirit that hovers around,
is dependent on continuation of the line.
But the whole history of ancestors stretching back,
uh,
is dependent on your having descendants and the whole future line,
which is perceived as sort of almost an existence or potential existence.
The whole line from the distant past going through you to the distant future is
all dependent on you having a descendants in male descendants in the line.
So the central purpose,
the central goal,
the central job of existence is to continue this line of fertility.
Now,
uh,
the traditional religion is based on,
this lineage idea.
Uh,
and because it's your own and the gods are in a sense,
your own ancestors,
people that you knew,
people that you talk to,
they stay more close to you after they die.
So unlike western God's where you pray,
but it's never clear whether your prayers are being answered or not.
Uh,
in an ancestor worship,
uh,
situation,
the answer right there and there,
you can talk back and forth with them.
They're not distant Erie,
supernatural kind of characters,
but rather like a grandfather who just stays near us after his death.
And this kind of description comes from the ethnography is the anthropologists
that go and talk to the people in these sort of traditional cultures.
The lineage head who is almost always the old,
the often the oldest male member of the lineage.
He often can communicate directly with these ancestors or there may be a
soothsayer in the community.
And then the,
the head man will commission the Soothsayer to ask the ancestors some a
particular question.
And the ancestors are quite available to discuss the most ordinary and mundane
issues of life.
Or they can discuss a very weighty affairs.
Uh,
this doesn't require waiting for some big holiday or some huge amount of time.
It can be the whole thing can be transacted in 15 minutes or maybe half an hour.
Sometime they contacted,
they provide their answers and,
and,
and you've got the answer that you need.
And so one of the interesting with respect to this course,
one of the interesting things that goes on is that family planning is being
introduced into Africa.
It has been now for quite a while and it's becoming available.
And so the people are thinking it over.
It's a hot topic.
They're discussing it.
They're trying to figure out whether it's good for them or not,
whether it's permissible for them or not.
What's going to happen if you use it,
what's going to happen if you don't use it?
It's a very hot topic and of course they want the wisdom of the ancestors on
this.
And so in the middle of this one set of demographers,
uh,
went into a,
in Ghana there's a,
a group of non Kona,
the name of the people there and they went into their villages and they wanted
to see how this worked out.
This discussion with the ancestors,
uh,
the,
as they call the traditional religion,
uh,
would be hostile to the introduction of family planning because elsewhere in the
world of course,
the more conservative,
the more it doesn't depend on the individual religion that particular religion
as,
as I have said and will say again.
Uh,
but it does depend on the religiosity of the person.
The more religious a person is in almost any tradition,
the more hostile they will be to change.
And in particular to the adoption of new reproductive practices like family
planning.
So they were interested in this issue,
how this would work out in,
in traditional villages in Africa.
So he asks the village head,
man,
uh,
one of the anthropologists,
to inquire of the spirits,
how many children should have family have simple question.
And here's what the spirit said.
Listen to what I have to say.
Children are the lineage.
If there are no children in the lineage,
the lineage,
if there are no children,
the lineage will end.
We ancestors want many children.
The women should give birth to many children.
Okay,
that was pretty clear answer.
There was no,
no fussing around with that one.
And,
but being western skeptics,
you know,
the democracy didn't really believe that,
that the ancestor was saying that.
Uh,
so he was saying,
well,
the head man put into the mouths of the spirits or whatever the head man
believed.
And that was not made the anthropologist quite satisfied with this.
But he was a clever,
a good scientist.
And he did the control experiment.
He asked the head man,
the same head man who had just reported the conservative views of the ancestors.
But what do you think got a completely different answer.
Women need to have just enough children currently it is very difficult to fend
for the children.
There's no food to feed them.
If they are in school,
it is difficult to pay their school fees and to buy them school uniforms,
taking them to the hospital when they're sick,
demands a lot of money.
Uh,
that is why we need to give birth to few children.
Oh,
well that's a little different take.
And so then the demographers brain starts rolling and says,
Aha,
now I got the scene.
Now I got it right.
Uh,
the ancestors are given the traditional point of view.
Well that's true.
That was what the older generation believed.
But the head men are part of the current generation and they're going to take
current views into consideration and take a more moderate view.
So they interviewed the next,
went to the next village and interviewed the next,
uh,
lineage head.
And that hypothesis didn't stand up speaking for himself.
The headman said,
I would like them to have many children because of a large following that makes
one a chief.
There's power in numbers.
So this is the idea that if you have only a few people in your village,
you're not very powerful.
Your neighbors can ignore you,
they can take advantage of you.
But if you have a big set of descendants and big family and extended family,
big village,
then you a powerful chief and he wanted children's so that he,
uh,
would be powerful.
Uh,
but the amp,
then this same guy was asked to,
well,
it has to see what the ancestors have to say about it.
And the ancestors said everybody should have a small number of children,
but they should not refuse to have children altogether.
And so since the ancestors are close at hand,
it's perfectly reasonable that they are aware,
uh,
of current trends.
And one of the ancestors said,
it is now difficult to get an education as well as to do farming.
If we're problem crops up and the child is sick,
then money is everything.
You have to buy medicine meaning modern medicine.
Uh,
and even if you go to the herbalist,
traditional medicine,
you need to take a foul,
a chicken or something along to pay for the treatment.
It's no longer the same as in the olden days when everybody did farming.
It's the ancestors speaking very well aware of current trends and,
and problems.
So after they interviewed a whole lot of these non villages in Ghana,
they summarize the research and the result was no pattern of responses at all.
Uh,
sometimes the head,
the head man and his ancestors,
they agreed.
Sometimes they disagreed,
sometimes it was the ancestor taking the conservative line.
Sometimes it was the head man taking the conservative line.
It was indeed like a discussion between um,
uh,
a man and say his grandfather,
that was going on.
And they will have different points of view and individuals,
uh,
will be different.
This contact with the ancestors seems quite natural because you read this story,
you know,
you're here.
This story is my God.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it's perfectly natural that people,
the,
the people in northern Ghana,
they have no word for supernatural.
It just doesn't exist.
They don't have any,
they aren't scientific explanations for anything.
So all explanations are sort of somewhere floating around.
Someone were empirical and observational and some of them are,
are supernatural.
And so there's no boundary between these kinds of explanations for things.
And so they don't have such a word and they don't distinguish the,
these kind of discussions with the ancestors from real things,
real dreams are,
or daydreams or any,
anything else.
It's all very fluid kind of thing.
Two people living in that kind of have a culture,
the western idea of an unwavering set of rules cast in stone in some book
thousands of years ago.
Like the Bible,
like the Koran,
uh,
would I,
it would seem ludicrous to not uncommon to them.
Our system of,
of,
of a book that says everything you need to know is as crazy as our view of them.
Uh,
talking to the ancestors and you should think,
compare this kind of individualistic,
flexible,
a style of religion to the mass monotheistic religions that we have in the
northern temperate zones,
least the western northern temperate zones.
These religions are all part of a big political structure which require
uniformity of the subjects of some king or some emperor and submission to that
person.
And of course,
as you probably all know,
the word Islam itself means submission.
And the ideal in monotheistic religions is often works.
Don't give me trouble.
Yeah.
Notice the uniformity.
This is women at at prayer.
I and notice the university as a CEO,
when you see a bigger picture of this,
this just a sea of women at some big event,
all dressed identically or looking identically.
When I was in Morocco,
I got a little instruction book that is given to children about how to pray and
every detail is specified down to when you're bowed down during prayer,
the position of the toes is specified or they crawled under or are they spread
out?
You have to to know that.
So conformity is a very important part of mass religion.
Of course,
in the West,
how is conformity enforced?
In Christianity,
you burn the heretical,
no long history of burning and killing by the dominant church.
Wherever it is,
you just slaughter the people that even on very tiny,
uh,
theological differences if they don't believe exactly as this as the authorities
think they should believe or would their head.
So it's a very different kind of pattern of,
of,
of cultural
understanding of,
of,
of religion and ancestors and the world.
Okay.
So given this intensity of devotion to the,
to the,
to the lineage,
uh,
the main virtue in Africa,
then his fertility,
uh,
the main sin is to be barren,
is to not have children and inability to have children.
Barrenness is not a just a passive thing that happens to you.
Uh,
but it's punishment for something bad that you have done.
And there's no distinct,
there's very little distinction between infertility.
The woman just can't get pregnant and,
and of course they don't accept the idea that it might be the man's fault,
but the woman doesn't get pregnant and she's infertile.
She has miscarriages goes partway through the pregnancy or infant deaths.
The important thing is to have descendants who can carry on the line and
however,
whatever the mechanism is by which a man or a woman or the family is incapable
of having descendants,
that's the worst sin and it's your fault.
It's not,
it's not a passive thing that that happens to you.
A barren women can be divorced,
they can be shunned and sometimes they need to,
they're not even allowed to live in the center of the village because of course
they have no scientific explanation for baroness.
But maybe it's catching and some sense either by evil spirits,
which are 10,
which are keeping the woman from getting pregnant.
You don't want the evil spirits to attack you or some other reason,
they can often be required to live on the edge of the village.
Given this emphasis on in one way or another,
getting pregnant.
Uh,
monogamy is not strictly enforced.
It's not the kind of obsession that it is in,
in the west.
Uh,
here's a wonderful story.
Recent 2000,
this is the People newspaper from Nairobi,
Kenya.
A group of woman stormed the Kenyan police station to demand that officer's
either make love to them or close illegal drinking dance.
They said the drinking made their husbands impotent.
You like that?
The women said the population of the district was falling off as a result of the
poor sexual performance of the men.
Uh,
they,
uh,
the,
the women,
uh,
it was Kindara actually north of Nairobi,
brought the businesses in town to a halt with their day long protest against
excessive drinking by their menfolk quote.
Our men have turned to vegetables.
They leave home early and come back and toxicant it.
There's no one to meet the sexual needs of the wives.
And guess which group it was,
uh,
where these women came from.
It was 24 Catholic Church groups in,
in Kenya.
They came together and demanded that the officer in charge of the police
station,
uh,
order his men to make love to these women.
The newspaper discretely does not say how the police responded to,
to this demand.
Now.
Uh,
so the women must be fertile and the man must be believed to be potent or,
or,
or fertile.
It's of course,
it's harder to tell whether the man is or isn't.
Uh,
the men of course,
uh,
in a sense want to keep the fertility of the women for themselves,
but it's more important to have children no matter who is the,
is the biological father and not only in the family,
but once a child is born,
perhaps under obviously uncertain circumstances,
the village will accept the,
the community accepts the children.
They need people,
they,
uh,
they want strength in numbers.
And so promiscuity is not frowned on,
particularly,
uh,
by,
the community.
Everybody knows it goes on and just kept quiet.
So I was reading,
uh,
this week and last a history of Lesotho.
Lesotho's a small country.
You've been there?
Oh,
no,
no.
Okay.
A small enclave totally surrounded,
uh,
by South Africa.
And this was,
uh,
a history of before the Europeans came about the 17 hundreds,
and there was a king then in king was a very small group at that time.
And not much more than a village.
And when the third son,
this is this a sort of a quote,
when the third son of the king died,
he left a widow who was still of childbearing age,
but had no surviving children by custom,
the widow should have gone to live with her husband's younger brother so that
she could continue the seed of her dead husband exactly as,
as we see in the old testament that we talked about last time.
But the widow didn't agree and she went off and actually got pregnant by sort of
a no good,
who wasn't even of that tribe.
Now this is a real,
a real,
no,
no.
And,
but nevertheless,
the child,
since that woman was legally part of a certain lineage,
uh,
that child by someone who wasn't even a member of the tribe and against the
convention was still accepted as a member of the kings,
a lineage there.
And it turns out that the child of this elite illegitimate in a sense child
became the greatest king that Lesotho has ever known.
A very important guy named Moshe [inaudible].
And Michelle show himself the grandson of the time I'm talking about,
he was reputed to have 140 to 200 wives.
You read the history.
They,
of course,
they have whatever written records they have.
And the,
the first one says,
well,
he,
when,
when he was young,
when he was 35 wives and he's 81 I said,
every,
every time this is reported as he gets older and probably accumulates more
wives,
uh,
the number goes up.
The last report was 200 wives because we don't know anything about the accuracy
of this,
but it would said most of his latter wives were regarded as distinctly inferior.
Michaud show would summon whomever he wished to spend the night with him.
And he undoubtedly sired avast progeny.
He also offered these lesser wives to visitors for the night by way of
hospitality.
But according to custom,
any children these visitors produced were regarded as Michelle shows own
children.
So again,
in the West,
uh,
chastity,
monogamy is valued who the father is in under populated culture and cultures
that have responded to under population.
It's the children that's wanted and they're,
the mechanism of,
of biologically fathering the child is,
is much less importance.
Uh,
I experienced this myself quite surprisingly.
I,
I think I mentioned I had been in Borneo living with some headhunters for awhile
and I got along pretty well with the young guys who sort of the guy stayed
together.
And so after I was there a little bit,
they offered me their sisters and said,
you know,
you shouldn't be sleeping alone and a discretion,
I won't tell you what happened.
So even now,
nowadays,
uh,
many African scholars maintain that African societies even don't even really
distinguish between legitimate and illegitimate births.
A 15 to 25% of women in various west and east African countries,
including Kenya for instance,
report premarital births.
So that's that.
They may or may not marry the guy,
but there's,
before marriage and as all these estimates of,
of behavior that is now becoming with the Christianization of the Islamization,
uh,
becoming somewhat questionable if the official physics are 15 to 25% for sure.
It's a lot larger than that.
Uh,
now,
of course,
the husband again isn't really wildly happy about all this playing around and
but what,
what most is important to him as his status.
The,
again,
the biological parentage of the child is,
is less important.
He knows whatever child his wife has will be officially his,
but he doesn't want to get to be known as impotent.
His potency is what matters to him.
So as long as the woman,
uh,
and this happens a lot because there's a very often the man is quite
significantly older than the wife,
especially younger,
you know,
as he gets older and accumulates more wives than younger wives.
And so his potency may really be flagging,
uh,
quite a bit.
So it's a real concern.
But as long as,
and if the wife,
it's,
if as long as the wife is discreet,
it doesn't make a public display that,
that this kid is really someone else's,
then,
uh,
not a big problem.
The father of the legal father accepts the child,
the community accepts the child.
So anthropology Curtis is very interesting and,
uh,
they won a wonderful,
Susan Watkins From University of Pennsylvania.
Sociologists works in Kenya in the low with the Louisville and the west of
Kenya,
[inaudible] people.
And she got together a focus group,
uh,
of women to discuss this issue.
It's a long thing.
I just tell you a little bit from it.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
Susan says,
so sometimes women were unfaithful,
you know,
pretending a western perspective.
And the women said yes,
being unfaithful started long time ago and other woman Lauren go,
the older woman,
the elder women will tell us that the only time you could sleep with another man
was if your husband was not able to make you pregnant.
But it's not that way anymore.
And so the moderator again ass and once you got the baby of the other man,
was it for your husband or the other man?
And notice the forest taken for granted that this is a gift.
And who did you make the gift for is the gift for your husband or a gift for the
other man.
And the women are somewhat incredulous.
Of course it is for your husband.
The other man is just like a bull.
Uh,
doesn't your cow wander?
And,
and mate with another bowl from,
from the next field when the cow gives birth,
is it,
is the calf yours?
Where's the calf and the owner of the other bull?
Of course it's yours,
you know,
the whole women join.
It's a wonderful,
uh,
kind of a little story.
And in this,
the women are kind of incredulous that Susan Watkins herself does not have any
cows.
They sort of presume that in,
in their answers that,
that she does.
And it's also pretty obvious how sort of,
matter of fact,
uh,
the women are about men's limited biological role is one might say,
and there's no romanticization of the relationship.
Uh,
none of the western fetish about biological paternity.
So not only his extra marital,
uh,
fertility not frowned on in the same way that it is at least officially here in
the West.
Uh,
but premarital promiscuity is reasonably acceptable.
So,
and,
uh,
not,
maybe not surprisingly,
uh,
y'all know about truck drivers going around spreading aids from village to
village.
Guess who else spreads?
Aid School teachers.
So school teacher is someone who has an education,
has been perhaps in the capitol or some big city,
has actually been to some sort of secondary or,
or college education and has a,
an income,
a white collar job,
a steady income from the government.
Teachers aren't much demand.
So this is a very high status person and he's assigning finishes.
College is assigned to some village in the bush and it's the,
maybe the,
the only,
the highest status person there.
So what do the parents of all the eligible daughters do?
They bring the daughter to them and offer him,
try out my daughter and uh,
which sometimes they do and sometimes they don't.
Uh,
but the statistics are now very clear that these teachers have picked up aids in
the city and they're one of the roots of spreading aids,
uh,
in the villages.
So along with this loose attitude toward paternity,
toward who was exactly the father,
uh,
the children that are held a lot to a large degree in common,
they do have a nuclear family.
We have a mother and a father of well-defined pair their children,
no question about who,
who are their children.
That idea of a nuclear family is not a common,
uh,
they're,
um,
30 to 50% when they survey.
30 to 50% of the children are not living in the compound with their biological
mother or father.
Uh,
in either case.
And nuclear family is,
let's see if I can get this one out.
Oh,
come back.
Yeah.
So very,
very simple things to find a nuclear family.
Uh,
how frequently does he does main meal?
That doesn't man,
it has made meal with his wife.
This gets studied how often he eats his,
made me with his children.
You know,
this is things that we take just absolutely for granted.
How frequently does his wife go with him when he visits friends?
How frequency does his wife go with him when he,
when he visits relatives and how much of his free time does he spend with his
wife and children?
And there's studies of this over the years.
Uh,
there's good study in Kenya for instance.
and the answer to all of these are rarely that there's,
there's a very low degree of new,
of nucleation of the families.
Again,
this is changing and families are becoming more and more nucleated.
And one of the things that studied is the percentage of people in marriages that
are considered nuclear.
And the last is a guy.
So I would like 21,
only about one fifth of families were what we,
what we would call nuclear families.
Just that idea of,
of a tight knit family exclusive.
And in many ways it's just not a common sort of thing.
Another,
a result of this attitude is what we might call a quayside prostitution.
Uh,
in that traditional system,
the f the father,
the husband is not necessarily required to provide economic support to the
children.
He's probably a rich man or has some land.
He gives that to his wife.
If he has several wives,
he divides it up among the wives.
They then grow the food on the land.
They also have to do some work on his land cause men don't want to work.
And so the wife has the responsibility for the children.
She must get the money for health.
She must get the money for education.
She does the farming on,
on her land.
So this puts the women in difficult straight and they're always needing
resources.
And if another man can come in and provide some resources for her and her
children,
well that's okay.
And so a fair amount of sex involves a,
shall we say,
a a gift from the hers.
And it's certainly not considered prostitution in that culture,
but we might use that word for,
but it's a very necessary part of the whole system that resources can come into
the mother child family,
other than from the legal husband who may or may not provide very much.
Now all of the,
the whole way the society is set up favors having a large number of children,
uh,
in,
in many different ways.
For instance,
sitter land tenure,
the idea of private property,
that one guy owns one plot of land.
It's a new idea there that traditionally the village or the community held a
bunch of property.
They would defend this against other villages.
So in a sense it was sun,
communities,
property,
but I,
and there was constant rating and constant station,
but they would try to defend their territory.
But within the territory of the land did not belong to any individual.
That,
and this was totally rational,
cause again,
very high death rates,
hard to keep people alive.
So one family would die out,
have no descendants,
another family would have many children.
So each generation,
the land just gets redistributed that and more or less equal amounts of land per
child.
However many children that you have.
And again,
land is not especially limiting.
So the result is that if,
if a male or wants to be powerful and have a lot of land,
which means that if one land,
one part of land goes bare fallow for some region reason,
he has other land.
So he wants to have a lot of children.
They all are guaranteed land and the more children he has sons and in usually in
the case,
the more his financial security,
his hunger,
security and his power goes up.
And the society supports this by giving land to whatever children.
Uh,
there are,
um,
this is,
I'm now breaking up because it's becoming impossible.
And again,
there are studies in,
in Kenya that in 1981,
the average land holding was 5.1 acres.
And the aggregately agronomists say,
and the local people are aware of this,
that about four acres of wood there technology of farming at that time about
four acres of good land are required an intense cultivation.
You have to really work it.
Uh,
we're required to support a family of the size of the,
the father's generation.
But even at,
at that time,
the system was to divide the land more or less equally among the sons.
Well,
if you take 5.1 acres and the average number of children was like for,
uh,
you get down to about one acre,
which is way below,
uh,
the amount of land that can support a family.
And so a crisis has eventuated and a variety of things happen that when the
economy is good in Kenya,
which is occasionally,
uh,
there are jobs in the cities and everyone hopes that one of their sons,
at least one,
will go off to the city and get a job and send back remittances.
But a lot of the time the economy is bad and the sons have to stay on the land
or migrate to the city without a job and become this kind of urban,
uh,
proletariat.
So under the influence of this,
um,
uh,
under the influence of this pressure,
the,
the number of children that have a lot of that,
of the average male wants,
has gone down from five to about three.
But still,
if you have two,
three acres and you're divided up three ways,
it's an impossible situation.
The Sun's cannot live on the land that you have given.
So while everybody's aware,
there's no ignorance or stupidity involved.
Everybody is aware of the situation.
The cultural prodding is so strong,
the history is so strong that the fathers don't want to reduce their desire,
uh,
for sons.
And when it's actually happening as the,
the number of sons desired has shrunk,
but from four point,
from 4.5 to three,
and currently if they divide up their land,
each child gets a half an acre,
whereas for are necessary to support the family.
So in respect to the,
the work on the farm that the man will usually own it,
that's varies in different parts of Africa own it in some sense while he's alive
goes back to the village on his death.
Uh,
and in the slash and burn agriculture that,
that really pre-modern peoples,
uh,
use,
the women do almost all the work.
The only thing that the men do is work that women are basically physically
incapable of doing,
which in this case,
if you're living in,
in the,
in the forest is clearing the land,
chopping down the trees,
hauling away the logs.
And this,
the men do,
it's heavy labor,
but it lasts about two weeks out of the year and the whole rest of the year it's
the women doing the work.
Um,
this,
uh,
and men don't like to in traditional these ultra,
I mean traditional cover that every period is traditional,
some period is traditional.
Whatever period you're talking about is traditional to some later period.
So it's,
it's not a great term.
Um,
so,
uh,
giving you a comparison,
in 1784,
when the United States was being settled,
uh,
there were 6,000 Arab oil spread across New York state,
but they were competing for land with 240,000 New Yorkers of European descent.
6,000 versus 240,001 tribe,
the Oneida from upstate.
And I was actually born up there,
uh,
had only 600 members to,
to the whole tribe,
but they inhabited 6 million acres of land.
And so this is the,
what's talked about by population,
low population densities,
600 people on 6 million acres.
And in as in Africa,
the women did most of the farming.
They had kind of a slash and burn agriculture also.
And the women did most of the farming,
well,
some of the colonists were friendly to the Indians and wanted to help the
Indians.
So they would suggest repeatedly that why don't you take up farming that with
your hunter and gatherer,
uh,
culture.
Uh,
you're never gonna have enough people to resist the Europeans.
If you want to resist Europeans and maintain some of your land,
you have to increase your population.
The only way to do that is you've got to go to agriculture.
But the men refuse to do that.
And they s one one quote,
one of the Iroquois farming is women's work.
Man was not made to go to work in the earth like a hedgehog put to go to war and
hunting.
So,
uh,
given that women are doing the work in many cultures,
they are very valuable.
And so bride price comes from this idea that in some sense you're buying one and
she is going to work for you.
And there's a very rough generalization then in cultures where the women do the
work and the farming work,
especially the man,
the,
the bride price.
We'll go from the man to the woman's family.
In other places like India,
many places in India where the women do not do the work but are sequestered and
kept at home,
may be covered up or something,
but only do internal household work,
then it reverses,
then the man is taking care of the woman and the woman's family must pay the man
or the man's family a dowery situation.
So,
uh,
the issue of dowery and bride price is extremely complicated and cultures handle
it very differently.
But that's sort of the rough generalization.
Um,
polygyny results from this since land is,
is traditionally not limiting.
Uh,
but the number you need women to work.
The Ma,
the land men of course,
won as many wives as possible,
uh,
possibly also for sexual reasons of,
of,
of course.
And again,
comparing North Africa with a sub Saharan Africa,
uh,
in North Africa and the Middle East,
about one to 7% of men or polygamous.
It,
it happens,
it's condoned,
but it's,
it's kind of a rare thing in the Mediterranean zone.
Uh,
even in the 19th century,
Mormons again,
desert people in the United States,
less than 10% of the men were polygamous.
So the maximum of course is 50%.
Polygamy can never go beyond 50% of the men,
cause one band has two wives,
then another man has no wives.
So,
so 50% of at maximum 50,
if they're limited to two wives and maximum 50% of the men can be polygamous.
And if some are allowed more than two wives or can manage to get more than two
wives,
than that maximum goes down.
So in Subsaharan Africa,
um,
and this is 1989 data,
uh,
in different places,
12 to 38%,
uh,
of the African men are in polygamous marriages.
So if they're limited to two and 50% is the Max,
those places where polygamy is 38% of the men means that most of the women are
in polygamous relationships.
Uh,
and again,
as we saw in New Guinea,
that a widow is very valuable.
Again,
the women are doing the work for you.
And so in Senegal,
for instance,
95% of the women who were widowed remarry within five years and 75% of these
widows are married polygynous Lee to man that already has wives.
Compare that to uh,
equally poverty stricken culture like Bangladesh.
This almost never happens.
That widow's get remarried in Bangladesh.
Polygamy contrary to the way we often perceive it as an abuse of,
of women.
Uh,
it is not usually considered an abuse there and women will often choose a
polygamous marriage over and monogamous mon one because what they want is a man
with resources and such a man will probably already have some wives the
otherwise act as a safety net,
uh,
and a support group.
So if the woman gets sick or her farming doesn't go well that year or for
whatever reason,
she can have a group of other women who will help her in a mutual kind of aid
society.
When a woman gets sick and,
and again,
sicknesses in premedical Saudis,
they're sick much greater fraction of the time than,
than we are.
And it's a big part of their lives and they have to prep for it.
They have children take care of and yet they're sick.
The other women can come in and also if they're circumcised and not in some of
the severe ways and not would say enjoying sexuality.
Uh,
the burden sometimes in many of these cultures,
the idea of female pleasure.
In some case it's known.
In some cases it's not known.
And it may be very painful if,
if she's had a circumcision operation.
So the burden,
so sexuality can be considered a burden on the women,
but if there's many wives,
that burden is spread around.
So in many ways,
um,
the,
uh,
po polygamy is an advantageous situation for a woman to be in.
So one,
one,
a anecdote here in Kenya,
in Kenya,
a white French woman,
anthropologists married an illiterate Mussai warrior,
she said,
and she wrote a biography.
She said that despite their cultural differences,
she and her messiah husband as well as his other wives got along famously,
he wrote this memoir and it was originally entitled the six wives of my husband
in a later edition.
It was Amanda to the nine whys of my husband in between.
He took three more wives.
Okay.
So I think you get the idea of what goes on in a society where land land is not
limiting.
People,
uh,
are,
are limiting.
Now you have to contrast this whole system to that.
In the temperate zones,
agriculture is much more productive in the temperate zones.
And the key switch is where a single man can buy as agriculture Evers or a man
or a woman depending can produce more food than he and his,
whatever his family unit is,
can consume so that there's an agricultural surplus.
In hunter gatherer societies,
there's basically no surplus.
In a lot of the early traditional African societies,
Uh,
this,
with this surplus,
of course they have more children,
the children are kept alive.
There's enough food for the children and the population starts growing and
eventually you,
you fill up the land.
And this Lusso Solo story that,
uh,
that I'm uh,
the story history.
There's several books on the history.
Uh,
the bond to peoples who,
again,
I mentioned the start in West Africa,
move east is just under this the hell and then come down the east coast of
Africa.
And at the period in the 17 hundreds,
they're sort of moving into southern Africa where conditions are pretty decent
and who's there?
The bushmen.
And they're kind of pushing the Bushmen al of this part of Africa in the 17
hundreds.
But the land is as they see it as open because the bushmen are very,
very sparse.
They're not a threat of any sort.
And,
and mostly,
uh,
the,
Montreux seem to take the Bushman's wives,
they don't seem to bother to kill the bushmen and just take their wives.
And um,
but later on by the 18 hundreds,
the land starts to get filled up.
And then not only do the bus,
who too with the,
were solo people call themselves by sue to start having conflicts among
themselves,
but the neighboring groups,
another bunch of group,
the Zulu,
which are big group generally called Zulu,
start getting political.
They start getting politically organized.
They tried to get land and you have tremendous wars in Zulu land,
which also slops over into the Bazuto land and tremendous destruction,
tremendous dislocation.
So again,
eventually,
uh,
the land fills up when you have the kind of decent agriculture that you have.
You can have an Lisel though,
which is again,
temperate zone and that south enough in Africa to be below the desert zone.
Uh,
the landfills up and all kinds of things change.
People come into conflict and because individuals can produce more,
more children than are needed to work the land,
each individual can produce more food than is required.
The excess children must go off and,
uh,
become basically a landless peasants looking for scarce work or go into some
villages are,
which eventually become cities and become landless laborers and the urban poor.
Meanwhile,
since there is this excess that now it becomes worthwhile for some people to get
control of others because that surplus in a situation where each man just
produces enough for himself and his wife and children,
if it's the man doing the work,
uh,
then there's no sense capturing him and enslaving him.
You know,
politically controlling him politically because he doesn't have any surplus to
give you,
for you to take.
Uh,
but once agriculture is productive enough so that he has a surplus,
then he has something worth taking and you start getting the,
the chief,
the chiefs want to become kings and they want to take over your land and they
want to control you and they want to get your surplus.
And actually civilization starts that way because with the surplus,
they buy luxury ornaments and they have craftsmen and they have trade and they
have scholars and they have priests and all this kind of stuff because not every
man is needed to farm the land.
So you both have as a result of an increasing population density,
the rise of civilization and the rise of a lot of the horrors of civilization.
These dent,
these massive wars and the massive poverty.
So this,
uh,
understanding of the dangers of overpopulation,
have been perceived for a long time.
Surprisingly early in history when local regions got filled,
but even surrounding them,
there could be lots of,
uh,
lots of empty space.
So here's a Greek Greek epic epic from around 700 BC.
There was a time when the countless tribes of Man Oh press,
the surface of the earth,
of the deep bosomed earth.
Deep doesn't mean deep soil,
deep soil,
earth and Zeus saw it and he had pity on the earth and in his wise heart resolve
to relieve the all nurturing earth of men by causing the great struggle of the
Trojan war.
That the load of death,
my empty the world.
And again,
this is his explanation for the,
for the,
this,
whoever wrote this epic explanation for the Trojan War,
that it was a mall and thing that they earth got too crowded.
People couldn't support themselves anymore and they had to be cleaned off.
Uh,
uh,
about 900 years later to Chilean Roman historian echoes this
200 a day.
The earth is currently more cultivated and developed an early times.
Now all places are accessible,
all are full of activity.
Everywhere there is a dwelling everywhere,
a multitude,
everywhere,
a government,
everywhere there is life,
we are burdensome to the world.
The resources are scarcely adequate to us and complaints are everywhere.
While already nature does not sustain us and he Chilean continues truly
pestilence and hunger and war and flood must be considered as a remedy for
nations like a pruning back of the human race becoming excessive in numbers.
That's quite lovely.
And of course,
Europeans are not the only ones to uh,
to worry about population in China.
In 500 BC,
Han fades who complained.
People at present think that five sons are not too many in each son has five
sons also and before the death of the grandfather,
there are already 25 descendants.
The women aren't counted.
Therefore people are more and wealth is less.
They work hard and receive little.
So this growing population density is well understood to be causing problems.
One of the problems that happens at population density is that communicable
diseases,
there's many,
many,
many pounds.
As the population gets denser,
the wars become larger,
maybe not as a,
as a percentage of the population,
but you have these enormous wars with enormous numbers of deaths.
Uh,
another thing is disease B starts spreading communicable disease because the
population has dense enough that uh,
the disease does not die out.
And again,
this local,
even though at the time of the Peloponnesian war in Greece,
uh,
about four 20 BC,
um,
it was written about in four 20,
uh,
a lot of,
a lot of that world was not Carter,
but Athens,
the Athens area was indeed a crowded and Athens itself was crowded.
And during the war they had,
everybody had get into the city and the city was blockaded and the population
density in the city with a strong enough set of plague,
some sort of plague.
We don't know what the disease was.
A broke out.
And this is just the acidities describing this.
Words indeed fail.
When one tries to give a general picture of this disease,
he's writing the Peloponnesian wars.
How many of you read the Peloponnesian war or some pieces of it?
Phew.
It's,
it's very interesting.
Words indeed fail when one tries to give a general picture of this disease.
And that's for the sufferings of individuals.
They seemed almost beyond the capacity of human nature to endure.
People were dying like sheep.
They died like flies.
The bodies of the dying were heaped one on top of the other.
And half dead creatures could be seen staggering about.
And the streets were flocking around the fountains in their desire for water.
The temples in which they took up their quarters were full of the dead bodies
who have people who had died,
uh,
inside them.
And he goes on to despair.
The result of this plague,
which is the people go into,
uh,
an emotional despair.
Civil society just collapses and all kinds of laws.
Lawlessness breaks out
in later Europe,
a
Europe under one huge vicissitudes of population in the classic ages,
up through Rome,
uh,
through the,
the whole Roman empire,
the population of the Mediterranean world was clearly increasing.
Whatever data we have always points to that.
Then starting with the dark ages,
maybe as early as three,
400,
uh,
Europe gets invaded by all kinds of quote barbarian hordes as,
as they are perceived by the Romans.
First it's the Germanic tribes,
then it's the huns,
then it's the Saracens and into the vikings.
And by the year 1000 European population is extremely,
uh,
cut down European civilizations cut down.
And we don't really have good ideas of why all these invasions stopped.
Uh,
one history that I particularly like says the reason they stopped,
there was nothing left worth taking in Europe.
So,
but about a thousand,
the,
the invasion stopped and then civilization started a recurring and it only took
about 200 years for Europe to basically repopulate itself.
When you have land,
when you have space,
uh,
people didn't have a lot of children and keep them alive.
So,
and in these good years,
it was good climate at that time.
Also life expectancies and the 12 hundreds,
we're between 35 and 40 years old,
which is,
which is very good for this very early era.
But then around 1250,
the population stopped increasing and for another hundred years or so,
it was more or less level.
And when you find a level population that means there's something limiting,
uh,
some block and they can't grow beyond this block.
And historians attributed to the whole sort of a state of culture there.
So the land was not owned by the peasants.
So the peasants,
you know,
if you own your own land,
you'll have a lot of interest in farming it maximally and improving it,
doing stuff when,
when someone else owns the land,
uh,
you don't have much interest in that.
And the worst,
the conditions you're under,
the less interest you have in improving the land for the land owner.
Cause he's going to take as much as he can weigh from you and leave you just the
bare amount that,
that you can live on.
So,
so at this time,
uh,
the Catholic Church was by far the biggest landowner in Europe and they own 30
to 50% of all the productive lands in,
in,
in Europe.
The peasants on the land were serfs and lived in this extreme poverty and they
were not allowed to leave the estate.
They were,
they were stuck there living in that kind of conditions.
Uh,
the ones that,
uh,
well the church itself got very rich.
This is a period of tremendous dominance of the church.
Uh,
they income of from church lands,
going to church,
nobility and to Rome was 10 times larger and all the church lands,
he had all the crown lands of all the crowns in Europe.
The church got 10 times as much income from their lands as did the so called
civil authorities.
The civil authorities controlled what was left of the land,
the kings and so forth.
And it turns out that the serfs on the civil and had somewhat better conditions,
somewhat more rights than on church lands.
On church lands.
They are really the lowest of the low.
But on civil lands they had somewhat better situation.
But are still deepen in poverty.
And so because of this serves just continue.
They were totally on educated and totally illiterate.
And so they continued to fort farm,
the small plots,
uh,
just as they've done for centuries.
And so the productivity of the land did not increase,
uh,
and the population could not increase.
Uh,
the Europe was full,
so it was no place that a surf could just run away and start his own farm.
Someone else,
because that land was owned already by someone else in the cities,
which were beginning little bit,
the guilds,
uh,
we're trying to keep members away.
They were closed.
They only took children of the members of the guild.
There was no way for someone to rise up and become a craftsman.
So historians describe this in about 1300 as an a through z and situation that,
that,
uh,
it's,
we'll talk more about mouth this later,
but a demographic and economic situation where you just can't support more
people.
The productivity of your system is just not enough to provide any more
population than you have.
And that if population rises,
something is going to come happen to knock it down again.
The thing that happened in Europe in this era is the plague.
Uh,
and the plague first hit in a Europe in Sicily in 1347 the previous time and had
been there with six to seven centuries ago in what's called the Justinian
pandemic,
the end of the Roman empire and the plague spread throughout Europe,
uh,
killing millions and millions of people.
Uh,
and it was wave after wave of this and there was a wave in 1347,
as I said,
the biggest initial way.
Then again,
1360 13,
71,
1381,
13,
88,
1398,
you know,
every few years to play good,
come through again and kill lots of people.
Uh,
numbers are hard to come by.
The most estimates say that about a third of Europe was killed by the plague.
Numbers can range from a sixth of Europe to a half of Europe,
but massive,
massive,
uh,
um,
death and brought Europe back down to below what you might call its carrying
capacity would that current technology.
So a plague,
they don't know why did play come into Europe at exactly this time.
And it may have been a random event,
but the one of the more reasonable ideas is that played kills and plague is
endemic in Asia,
but it has to get from Asia to Europe.
And if someone was,
we're traveling from Asia to Europe,
they would be dead before this period.
There would be dead long ago from the plague.
But in the early Middle Ages,
uh,
traveled on a ship shipping and all kinds of travel,
we're getting better and faster.
And so one of the things that plague may have been able to get to Europe because
a ship leaving the Black Sea,
where apparently is where they caught her from,
could get to,
to Sicily before everyone,
everyone who had the plague,
everybody on the ship was dead.
That's,
that's one one hypothesis.
So it took from this nice high level and 1250 and so forth,
a stagnant period and then it was knocked down.
It took hundreds of years,
minimum 200 years before the population of Europe recovered to its 1300 1340
levels.
And some historians think it didn't really recover until about 17,
15,
so 400 years or something to recover from.
From this.
The play continues for hundreds of years and more than 300 years after the
plague started,
it killed more than 70,000 people in London alone.
One city.
And this is Daniel Defoe,
the journal of the play gear.
Your,
some of you have probably read that,
uh,
really horrible.
So that's 16,
64 and 16,
65.
No more than 300 years after the plague starts.
Well,
one of the reasons it's persisted as they,
the people had absolutely no idea what was causing the plague.
Absolutely no idea what to do to protect yourself from the plague.
No,
I no real idea of con contagion or contamination.
Uh,
and there was no,
no science whatsoever.
This is before the enlightened,
before rational attitudes toward all these things.
So what would someone believe back then not having any sort of real
understanding of,
of,
of the whole disease process and infection process?
Well,
pretty obvious.
It's God's punishment.
You know,
humans are sinful.
We all know that.
And so God is punishing you.
Well what do you do if you've been a bad boy,
you have to get punished.
So Penitence and people would whip themselves.
They called the flatulence and have you any,
any of you seen the seventh seal?
Ingmar Bergman.
And you know this is a great movie.
It starts at,
it's,
it's set at this time in Europe and the opening scene is sort of a bleak baron
European landscape with a long line of pilgrims going through each one with a
whip beating the guy bloodied the guy in front of him.
This is a toning for their sins.
And this was a way that they intended to try to stay alive.
What was the actual result of this?
They're weakening themselves.
They're cutting holes in their skin,
which is a barrier to penetration,
low flea bites,
Carrie,
Carrie plague.
So these were sick,
desperate people and they were going from town to town.
So they would pick up plague in one town,
carry it to the next carrier,
the next character next.
So the very mechanisms by which they were trying to keep the plague away was
exactly one of the major mechanisms of the spread of the plague.
And if you read the history of the time,
there are all kinds of of of crazy what we consider crazy things that they
tried.
So syphilis was introduced to Europe,
uh,
at,
at about that time from the new world.
So we're talking,
uh,
you know,
150 years later and while it was a new,
a new thing on the horizon and die,
a number of doctors somehow got the idea that syphilis would protect you against
the plague.
So one of the standard cures was to get infected with syphilis as a form of
protection from the plague.
As far as we can tell,
this was a remedy taken up only by rich people,
whether true or not,
I don't know.
So,
but the plague being a very major demographic event,
knocking the population of Europe way down was,
it was one of the seminal
landmarks in European civilization and marked a complete change in how European
civilization developed.
And so I described a medieval Europe is having this sort of an through z and
kind of landlock,
uh,
that things are unchanging and couldn't change because no one was allowed to
change.
Uh,
and then all of a sudden you get the black death and then immediately after the
black death,
you get the renaissance.
What happens is a lot of fluidity.
People can leave.
The church estates can leave their lords estates.
There's plenty of empty land.
They go out there,
they can farm it themselves.
The guild's don't have members.
They can join guilds,
they can do technology,
they can move around,
uh,
all kinds of things,
turn up.
So the first and most of the very old wave of the plague lasted from 1340s to
1400,
and the next generation was the core of the renaissance.
So 1420 a Brunelleschi designs,
the great dome of the Cathedral in Florence,
uh,
Ghiberti is creating the great bronze doors,
for the door of Florence's.
Baptistry you've got done.
A Tello makes the first.
David,
I don't know if you ever,
you know,
Michelangelo's David,
but Don told me at a very delicate one beforehand,
which is very different but equally beautiful.
Uh,
Davinci.
Michelangelo all worked in the 14 hundreds,
Machiavelli,
the metta cheese or the century,
and at the end of the century,
1492,
Columbus discovers America.
So you have,
you go from this,
you know,
extremely tight,
locked in medieval thing,
lasting hundreds of years were basically almost everybody's miserable unless you
were a lord or a bishop.
Uh,
and then boom,
you reduce the population pressure and the world explodes in creativity.
Now that's not everybody has to agree that that was the seminal event that
caused the renaissance and some Sim.
Nothing is that simple,
but who clearly was one of the major things that one has to consider in
discovering your why did the renaissance,
uh,
happen?
And there were of course,
antecedents to the renaissance before that.
As I said,
European civilization started recovering in the year 1000 well before the
plague.
So that's a simplistic explanation,
but certainly,
uh,
an important part of what was going on.
Okay.
Um,
now we're almost out of time,
but even after the renaissance and continuing up until surprisingly modern
times,
uh,
people still live very badly,
better than before,
but still badly.
So from the time of the black death till the industrial revolution started
making things better,
we're talking something like 1350 to maybe 1850,
with,
you could push that back to 1800 if you want.
Uh,
so we have about 500 years again,
where the population pressure is not great.
Civilization is improving,
is making great advances in terms of,
of our culture or exploration of the world.
Uh,
but the common man doesn't really see much improvement in the situation at all.
the population is still overwhelmingly made up of peasants just living on the
edge of existence.
And this is a description.
A typical house in Europe in the late middle ages is made of wood or various
scraps.
So vegetable material mixed with mud or clay.
The roof is of Straw or reads the floors of dirt,
and there's a pit in the middle for fire.
If it is winter,
the family huddles cold together around the fire.
And semi-darkness well with the animals nearby for warmth,
one of the reasons for living with the animals is so the warmth the animals
produce and they don't understand ventilation and ventilation.
You bring in cold area.
He didn't let it go out,
so they don't want the cold air coming in.
So they close themselves up,
but they need a fire to keep from freezing.
So the room is filled with smoke,
would may be a small hole for the smoke to go out.
So they're,
they're not breathing fresh air.
Uh,
this is a description of late middle ages.
300 years later,
there's little progress.
Uh,
one of the great French historians,
yours,
who pair has studied a,
a village in France and the 16 hundreds and as Senali and it was a village about
500 to 700 people.
One third of the babies died in their first year,
another third died before adulthood,
plus only one third survived to reach the reproductive ages.
Remember I showed you that graph from Roman times?
Same,
same story,
1500 years.
And basically,
no,
no progress.
Little children who managed to survive.
We're good.
Looking little children,
but if they reach the age of 10 or 12,
that you had already assumed to generally unpleasant appearance of adults,
the people tended to be stunted,
bent over and have a yellowish complex complexion.
They did not look healthy.
Their bellies were distended,
lack of lack of protein.
They move slowly.
They had poor teeth.
That growth was retarded.
He has village records from this era of the 350 births,
only 145 would reach adulthood and Marion turn.
But of the 75 female survivors,
marriage is almost universal.
Again,
if a woman manager and she was going get married and start Sean Berry,
but since they were a unhealthy,
they didn't have good nutrition that the girls did not reach,
uh,
men sees until about the age of 18.
And finally they started menstruating and became fertile.
And so they married late about age 23.
They just weren't healthy enough to engage in a marriage before that,
uh,
childbearing was almost universal.
Uh,
marriage and childbearing was almost universal.
And we'll see this again in China,
but maternal death severely cut short,
the period of childbearing having a child itself is extremely dangerous.
And of the third of the one third that reached marriageable age,
uh,
most couples had only one or two children before either the husband or the wife
died.
So again,
the limitation on the number of children is poor nutrition,
late maturity,
leading to late marriage and then early death.
And uh,
they have only one,
one or two children.
The end result of his statistics there is that the,
by the,
by the time a hundred female children of the preceding generation had died or
finish the reproductive years,
they'd produced only 70 daughters.
The population was not replacing itself.
This is one of those situations where if no one comes in from the outside,
that village is going to go extinct.
But there were other places with apparently somewhat better agriculture that did
produce a surplus of children and they wandered around looking for some home and
the village made up the deficit by marrying,
uh,
excess people may be the daughter of Tran drawer's of tranche and artisans are
laborers.
And again,
as we saw in the underpopulated areas of New Guinea,
when a man died,
uh,
leaving a wife,
no time was wasted.
The widows and widowers remarried right away.
Uh,
and uh,
and if since land was so scarce that a lot of these,
a lot of the marriages and another reason for the late marriage was they had to
wait until the father died.
And that was important for working the land that was so much land and could
support so many people you need.
And you had so much labor that was required to work that land.
The father died.
That's when they died fairly young when they're still being able to work so that
Labor is gone.
You have to take in a wife to replace the labor of the dead father.
Then the children come on in the generation.
Uh,
it keeps repeating,
okay,
this situation that [inaudible] is an in France or was characteristic of France
for 400 years and during that time the population just hovered around 20
million.
It,
uh,
came out of the black death and rose to 20 million and then they were not able
to get over that for the ballpark of,
uh,
a 400 years,
um,
in,
okay.
I think we're,
we're,
we're about to tell you that the population started to recover then late in this
period and by 15,
60,
and had really returned to the 20 million of before the black death.
This is France.
But then religious fervor a starts up,
uh,
in the wars of the 16th and 17th century.
And you know,
the hundred awards between the Catholics and the Protestants in Europe.
And previously the Christians had had religious wars always against Islam.
They were there.
That was,
that was the main enemy.
The Turks were very strong and much more advanced than the Europeans.
And they were battering at the doors of Europe.
They surrounded Vienna.
And so all of the military activity was a religious origin was against the
Turks.
But that threat receded and now you have the reformation and now you have to
both Christian religious groups within Europe and they start going after each
other.
And,
uh,
about a quarter to half of the German speaking peoples of Central Europe were
killed.
Uh,
in this period.
It was really most severe in Europe,
in France.
It was sort of stamped out that early on in this period,
uh,
Protestants were doing very well in France and had a large fraction of the
population.
But have you heard of Saint Bartholomew's Day on that day?
The,
the,
the was also had to do with the royal succession.
Uh,
the Catholic force has got together and just slaughtered all the Protestants
they could find.
And that sort of stopped the reformation,
uh,
in France.
So Europe again,
uh,
went through then 130 years of,
of,
of this Catholic Protestant bloodletting before they finally realized that this
was not a wise thing to do.
Right.
We're continue with what happens to European civilization after,
uh,
these slaughter of the religious slaughter Di dies down.
See you on Tuesday.